this morning president Trump endorsed
Republican Senate candidate Roy Moore
despite the fact that Moore has been
accused of molesting minors yeah yeah
when asked why he endorsed more Trump
said US gross guys got to stick together
we got together
[Applause]
[Applause]
Trump did create a lot of controversy by
endorsing Roy Moore today Trump praised
Moore as someone who reaches out to
young people so that's the kind of show
you're gonna have tonight by the way
feel free to get your money back if you
want
speaking of Trump a new book came out I
don't if you heard about this Andy a new
book claims that for Donald Trump the
four basic food groups are McDonald's
KFC Pizza and Diet Coke yeah yeah yeah
yeah when they heard this the American
people were outraged and said Diet Coke
what's your problem snowflake why can't
we just listed what he eats and people
here very happy with it yeah and I gotta
say I thought it sounded pretty good to
economist of course you everyone talked
about the tax bill economist project
that the new Republican tax bill will
lead to a one trillion dollar deficit
one trillion dollar deficit yeah it's
the first thing to lose the lose one
trillion dollars since the emoji movie
[Applause]
anyone here see that by the way what do
you mean whoa that's not the correct
response I paid good money it was
horrible
due to the harassment scandal Matt
Lauer's wife has now left the country
yeah she said I want to be where in the
world Matt Lauer isn't
what the hell was that they didn't laugh
they're like ah
yeah well that does fit with the I think
maybe they were just making sure you
didn't feel but yeah oh yeah yeah that's
what they're here for
that's what they're here for Time
magazine has published a short list of
nominees for Person of the Year and it
includes colin kaepernick donald trump
and robert muller yeah and if it's a
three-way tie that's gonna be one
awkward photo shoot I'm not taking the
knee
hey it's come out that Beyonce changes
her email address on a weekly basis yeah
and get this it's because of me
[Applause]
you